حرب اوكرانيا الساخنه تدخل الشتاء باردا
قد تلجم ثلوجه حده المعارك الهدوء النسبي
على الجبهات فرصه للطرفين الاوكراني
والروسي لتعزيز قدراتهم العسكريه
شبكه سي ان ان نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين
ان اداره بايدن تدرس توسيعه تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه هذا الشتاء بناء على طلب
منذ بدايه الصراع في فبراير الماضي دربت
الحليفه واشنطن عده الاف من الجنود
الاوكران في مجموعه صغيره الا ان
التدريبات المتوقعه ستكون اوسعه كما ونوعا
واكثر شمولا وكثافه لكيفيه العمل في تكوين
العسكريا متماسك
عن طرق للتاكد من ان الاوكرانيين لديهم
المهارات التي يحتاجونها للنجاح في ساحه
المعركه حيث تدافع اوكرانيا عن اراضيها من
العدوان الروسي
منذ بدايه الحرب تتعاونوا المانيا مع
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا لتقديم
التدريب للقوات الاوكرانيه وفي حال
الموافقه الامريكيه على نظام التدريب
الجديد ستكون قاعده فراجين فور العسكريه
في المانيا هي التي تطلع اليها القياده
العسكريه الامريكيه نظرا لحاجه التدريبات
الى مجموعه اكبر واكثر تنوعا من المدربين
وقت المستقبل
في العام 2023
اكثر من 300,000 تم التدريبهم في اكثر من
100 ساحه التدريب في روسيا بلا روسيا كما
تم انشاءه ساحه تدريب جديده ومتعدده
الانواع في اقليم كرسناير
حول مدى اهميه التدريبات العسكريه في ساحه
المعركه
الاساسي في الحرب الان هو كم الذخيره
المتوفره لدى الطرفين يبقى عمر العربيه